going to be Suraj maladi he is going to
talk about the learning through the
grapevine
great everyone thanks for coming and
thank you to the organizers for inviting
me so today I'm presenting joint work
with Matt Matt Jackson and David McAdams
this is titled learning through the
grapevine
um if uh if you'd like to ask a question
and the mic isn't near you you can just
ask me and I'll remember to or I'll try
to remember to repeat your question for
the folks online
that
so in this paper we develop a pretty
simple model of social learning where
agents are connected with each other in
a network
and some of these agents receive
informative signals about a state of the
world whether or not avocados are good
for your cholesterol
and then they're going to share this
information with some noise with their
neighbors
you then share that information again
with some noise with their neighbors and
so on
a basic question we ask in this context
is how hard is it
for agents to learn as the distance
between them and the primary sources of
information grows large
the main negative result that we build
up to over the course of this talk is
that typically it's going to be
impossible for agents to learn meaning
that even if you stack the deck in favor
of these agents by assuming that they're
perfectly patient by assuming that they
have access to arbitrarily many primary
signals
but in fact assuming that they know how
far away these primary sources are from
them in the network
even if you endow them with all this
information and the ability to process
it it's going to turn out that they're
going to learn very little from the
information that sort of trickles down
to them through their social network
so that's the the the goal of this talk
will be to build up to and state this
result precisely I'll give you some
intuition for why it holds and then I'll
comment a little bit more about how we
might interpret
so I mentioned noise a couple of times
in the previous slide so let me give you
some examples that motivate how we think
about noise in this model so Simmons
adamic and Adar give the following
account of a series of tweets that were
sent out
initially someone wrote street style
shooting in Oxford Circus for Asos and
Diet Coke let me know if you're around
this got picked up and uh retweeted with
the following text someone wrote
shooting in progress in Oxford Circus
what
which then got retweeted as shooting in
progress in Oxford Circus stay safe all
within the span of three minutes
give you another anecdote the
Yellowstone volcano Observatory it's the
following story they they wrote an
article about repairs that they did for
a monitoring station that was damaged
during some storm
a tabloid newspaper picked up on this
article and wrote another article
implying that Yellowstone was
unmonstered
and finally a few social media news
outlets picked up on the Tabloid article
and uh continue to perpetuate the same
misinformation and in fact had the same
misspellings that the Tabloid article
had
was there also a whole set of tweets and
retweets about that were correct
so you show you know they can go off in
different directions and different you
know so
um so again narratives for example so
the question was uh prior to this were
there a set of tweets that were correct
or parallel to them
um I don't know
so I know that uh in at least in this
previous example that uh it started out
uh sort of a a real message that was
correct and this then got mutated uh in
the second account I don't I don't
remember the details of the story
yeah
some of the
just end up with lots of variations
that's what I'm thinking right you end
up with variations
at all sorry
so uh I think uh the question was about
uh parallel mutations and communication
that might be happening now foreign
people can't learn right but can they
approximately learn so that we sort of
have people so we might see these these
weird retweets but how important are
they relative to sort of the other
varieties that are out there which are
relatively accurate that's kind of I
mean how how serious is this particular
phenomenon of that that's relative to
this in this story that you may have
seen lots of things that were
much much much closer to the actual
truth of the event initial event yeah so
in this context
um again maybe maybe this might uh be
easier to answer uh once you see the
model but we'll assume that there are
some primary stories and you know
there's uh real information out there
but ultimately what trickles down to you
is information that went through a lot
of uh message passing right and here you
know you know how long are chains of
miscommunication in real life and how
frequently does this kind of thing
happen I don't have a great answer to
that and maybe you can try to think
about that by you know through
introspection but here are at least a a
couple uh examples where we have some
quantitative information
and so adamic gives this example of a
message about uh Healthcare that got
reposted over 470 000 times within
around 11 mutation rate and this ended
up producing over a hundred thousand
variants of the same me and this was
pretty typical for the other viral means
that they had in their data set
and out of thousands of meetings most of
which were actually not viral uh the
typical distances that these messages
traveled uh when they were reshared was
in the dozens
to give you a very different example
Gary 2016
um uh notes that there are over 500 000
textual variants of the Greek New
Testament
and this is not including uh spelling
errors these are substantive changes to
the meanings of certain passages so this
sort of indicates that there might be
non-trivial mutation rates in many
conflict
s so paying off of these examples we're
going to build a very stylized model
there's going to be a binary state of
the world zero or one
and there's a probability Theta that the
state of the world is one
now there are going to be some nodes
we'll call sources who hear informative
IID binary signals about the state of
the world these signals will also be one
or zero to reflect the underlying state
and this information they're then going
to noisily relay to their neighbors
I mean by noise well there's going to be
probabilities mu Sub 0 1 that a message
of a type zero it morphs into a message
of type 1 at some step of communication
and similarly there's a probability of
mu sub 1 0 that a message of type 1
Works into a message of type zero
and I'm going to assume that these
mutations are IID at every single step
we want to allow for these message
specific mutation rates because if if
for example one represents a more
exaggerated version of a message and
zero represents something that's more
muted people might have a greater
propensity to move from zeros to ones
than vice versa
in addition to mutations there are also
transmission failures because things
that are shared might not actually be
heard and things that are heard might
not be shared
so I might send uh Ben an email about a
funny joke
um but it might just end up sitting in
his inbox or spam folder so he might not
hear it or alternatively he might have
opened it up and seen it and uh thought
this is decidedly unfunny and uh chooses
not to share it with any of his friends
so there's a probability P sub 1 of a
message type one surviving and a
probability piece of zero of a message
type zero surviving and with
complementary probabilities these
messages get dropped okay and again we
want to in general think about cases
where P sub 1 is different than P Sub
Zero if for example a one message
represents a more significant scientific
result or a funnier joke or a more
salacious rumor then it's more likely to
get passed along than a type zero
message but for now I'm not going to
open this can of forms I'll talk about
that later and I'm going to assume uh
that P1 equals P naught equals sub P for
Simplicity the first part
okay so this is the sort of picture that
you should have in mind for how message
passing looks here there's an initial
node that we're calling the source or
original sender who hears a private some
primary information exogenous to this
network
this agent then noisily relays this
information to his neighbor and this
process continues and at the end of this
chain sits someone who we're calling the
receiver or learner
the receiver is going to update uh his
belief about the state of the world
given what he learns through this chain
of message passing or given what he
doesn't hear
just to break this down a little bit
more if you start out with a one message
then it can get passed along Faithfully
as a one
it can mutate into a zero or it can get
dropped
if it's passed along Faithfully as a one
this process continues itself
if it mutates into a zero
again this message gets forwarded but
now with different survival
probabilities and different mutation
probabilities
If the message is dropped then it
remains dropped there's nothing to share
uh for the for the rest of the chat
and so here uh the state of a message
that's getting shared this way you can
represent this message as a markup chain
which takes on the values either one
zero or is dropped and being dropped is
an absorbing State this is just the
transition Matrix down here
so you know we've seen uh uh two very
nice talks earlier today uh which
involved strategic agents making
decisions on how they should be sharing
information
um and sort of give it given given what
they learn here agents are totally
mechanical okay so we're focusing only
on the question for some reason or the
other
um they're sharing this information that
uh the probability with which they share
depends on the nature of the message but
we're not concerned with why they're
sharing we're only concerned with the
difficulty of learning
so so far we've considered what happens
along a single chain of communication
but in general
same receiver is going to have access to
multiple different chains of
communication all leading to different
primary sources
suppose for example this receiver has n
of t uh chains of length T leading up to
various primary sources and that there's
independent message passing along each
of these chains
the truth is the primaries yes that's
right so all the primary sources uh are
going to hear signals about the true
State rule
yeah the in between people only hear it
from One Source because they're not
aggregating they're just
they just have movie transmission so for
now think of it as independent chains
and I'll show you a picture to showing
that yes they could be a network where
they're hearing from multiple sources
but again
um as long as people are uh taking each
individual message and passing it along
with some independent probabilities it's
not going to matter whether they hear
multiple sources we're going to focus on
one agent in this network uh who's
saying that right so so I'll show you a
picture I don't update my belief
it's
okay
so you will update your beliefs so so
I'm going to get there the agent so the
question was uh do agents update their
beliefs
um messages are going to be shared
you're going to take stock of what
you've heard it's going to be a bunch of
ones and zeros and you're going to
update your beliefs on the basis of that
but what you hear isn't going to affect
your share that's
and so here there is a race now okay all
right yeah so p is non-zero then the
message always gets strong right with
probability one as the chain goes well
right yes
are you going to look at the setting
with P0 is that no so uh I'm going to
look at the the following race so keep
me up from my next point which is that
if these chains are getting long exactly
as you've noted
probability that I hear a message from
an individual chain is going to go to
zero moreover even if I do hear a
message from that chain
could have been noise up multiple times
along the way and so it might be a very
very little resemblance to the initial
message that was sent out right and so
as a chain is getting longer there's
less information containment
but at the same time if n is increasing
in t then I have access to multiple
chains and the goal of this paper is to
characterize situations when these
countervailing forces go into favor
learner and she ends up learning the
true state
and to the end we're going to Define
this object B of T which is the
posterior probability of the learner
that the state of the world is one given
the information she heard from n of T
independent chains of communication
that's going to be some subset of nft
signals which are going to be ones and
zeros
so this is the kind of picture you can
keep in mind
here there are eight sources
and the learner is the root of this
inverted tree
and these sources are a distance three
away from the learner
so suppose that the state of the world
is one
everyone hears a signal about the state
of the world most people heard one uh
but this guy over here got a mutated
signal here's a zero this guy over here
had a transmission failure doesn't hear
a signal
these messages are then relayed to the
agents at the next level of the tree
again with the same noise
there are some mutations some messages
get dropped
and independently each of these messages
are now getting communicated again to
the next level uh of the tree so there
was a message that got dropped here
here there was a mutation and finally
the receiver ends up hearing uh four of
the eight initials messages that were
sent out but also knows which one like
how many were dropped
no exactly yeah
knows how many knows how many were
dropped
it's unrealistic but it's where where
I'm trying to go is even if they have
all this information they still won't be
able to learn but this is very semantic
but they're not it also learns from
hypnosing Network on from where which
messages yeah
yeah
but it doesn't see the intermediate
message
it doesn't see the intermediate messages
there are just some messages that got
noise up and and reached this issue
and so in this example the uh the
learner cares four signals three of
which are ones and one of which is a
zero
I'm going to Define uh one more object
before I get to results
so I'll call F of t a threshold for
learning
the posterior belief of the learner
converge to one or zero
whenever asymptotically
this learner has access to more than F
of T chains
St grows large
and the posterior belief of the agent
converges to Theta meaning she learns
nothing at all
whenever uh asymptotically the agent has
fewer than F of T sequence
it's a threshold because if I if I learn
more than fft signals as as T grows
large I learn the truth
if I hear from fewer than F of T signals
as T grows large I don't learn anything
the basic result is that
if p is greater than zero and mu 1 0 and
mu zero one are less than one half then
thresholds for learning exist okay in
particular it's the given by the
following expression what's important
here is that the threshold for learning
is exponential in t
so as distances between the learner and
the sources is growing large
I need to hear from at least
exponentially more signals in order to
be able to learn the truth if I hear
from fewer than that I'm not going to
learn anything
now we can recast this uh uh result for
the case where the information Network
takes the shape of a tree
in that case we would say that whenever
the expected degree if it's a random
tree is smaller than this expression
over here the agent isn't going to learn
and whenever it's greater the agent will
learn as the tree grows deeper
I'm not mistaking you
um
each message to our signage
independently right that's right if it's
already case that I just drop it all the
messages on an edge all together or or
if all of them would take the same thing
simultaneously do you know how the
thresholds will change
um that's a good question so I don't
know how the thresholds would change in
that role and it's you could you might
imagine for example that if some of
these agents are biased in One Direction
or likely to drop everything and you're
in this tree that they you know all the
zeros and ones become one so all the
messages get dropped that's a natural
sort of question we don't have results
for that do we know if that would be a
threshold threshold learning result if
there would be a threshold so my
intuition is that then you're going to
have dependence on the shape of the
network here what we're doing you have
no dependence on the way that the
network looks right these could be
independent chains these could be trees
right and so whether or not you get
these threshold rules I think would
depend on this network structure in that
case
now we have uh the main result
paper which is that
if the learner doesn't know
new one zero over mu01 which are is the
relative mutation rates
but has an atom list prior over this
object that has a connected support
then for any n of T no matter how
quickly it's growing in t
the learner is going to learn nothing in
the limit
the posterior beliefs are going to
converge to exactly Theta which was per
prior
note in particular that we didn't put
very strong conditions on the kind of
Prior for which this result goes through
in particular even if the learner has
only an Epsilon uncertainty
over these relative mutation rates
it's going to be impossible to learn
meaning a prior over this that has
support of length Epsilon so he's really
really certain about what it is just has
some slight uncertainty it will still be
the case that the learner won't be able
to learn anything
so let me try to give some intuition for
where this result is coming from
consider the following simple example
suppose that the probabilities of
transmission are one
and uh let mu sub zero one equal Alpha
times pi is the
um probability that a zero mutates into
a one and let mu sub 1 0 be Alpha times
one minus pi
and I'll assume that Alpha is known but
Pi is unknown
and instead the learner has a prior on
Pi that's supported
on a tight interval around one-third
it's ordered on one-third minus Epsilon
to one-third plus Epsilon
so what happens in the case where
primary sources are direct friends
of the learner Okay so this is the case
that I'm considering here here's the
learner and the Learners just directly
connected to a ton of primary sources
foreign
if the state of the world is one
then we have a lot of sources
the fraction of one signals that we see
should converge to 1 minus mu 1 0.
so the only way we won't see a one
signal from a given primary source is if
there was a mutation
and so the fraction of one signals we
see is just the probabilities that there
was no mutation of one into a zero
so this is converging to one minus mu
one zero
and L of one is a lower bound on this
guy over here why is it a lower bound
well in place of Pi we replaced it with
the lowest value that Pi could possibly
take on which is 1 3 minus Epsilon
if the state of the world were zero
then the only way in which we're going
to see a one is if there was a mutation
along one of these steps of
communication right
and so the fraction of ones we see is
the probability of a mutation happen
okay so the fraction of ones we see is
going to converge as and one grows large
to just this mutation rate of zeros into
ones
and an upper bound on this guy is
one-third plus Epsilon times Alpha right
we just replace Pi with the largest
possible value it could take
and let's call this upper bound M of one
it's clear that when Alpha is small
M of 1 is a lot smaller than L of one
right because here we're adding a 1
minus Alpha
so you're going to be able to learn the
true state of the world the state of the
world is identified from from looking at
these uh the fraction of ones that you
see because in the case where the state
of the world is one you're going to see
uh more than L of one signals in the
state of the world where uh where Omega
is zero you're going to see fewer than M
of one sentence
okay so the sensible thing happens when
we're directly connected to these direct
sources
so the weirdness is coming from uh the
case where T is large
so let's suppose again that the primary
sources now are a distance T away but
again we have access to a lot of primary
sources they're n of T primary sources
if the state of the world is one
now
a tight lower Bound for the fraction of
ones that we see is given by the
following expression which I'm calling L
of t
where do we get this from well we're
going to see a one if along that chain
of length T there was no mutation
right that's one case the other case is
there was a mutation
but the last mutation was a zero into a
one rather than a one into a zero
right because the last mutation is going
to determine what we what we ultimately
see from that chain
and a lower bound on that guy again is
one-third minus subsequent
again an upper bound on the fraction of
ones that we see in the state of the
world where
Omega is equal to zero is
probability that there is a mutation
right because now the zeros are what the
primary sources heard so there has to be
a mutation for us to see a one and
moreover the last mutation should be a
zero into a one
now when T is large this guy is going to
zero
and so what you're really comparing is
one-third minus Epsilon times some
object versus one-third plus Epsilon
times some object
and so for T large enough M of T is
going to be larger than L of t
what that means is that even when n of T
is large
If the percentage of ones that we see
Falls in this interval or between L of T
and M of t
then we can come up with stories for
what pi must have been to rationalize
the state of the world being one or to
rationalize the state of the world being
zero
so I could say to myself
the reason I'm seeing so many ones is
because truly the state of the world is
one
or maybe the reason I'm seeing so many
ones is because the state of the world
is actually zero but more people are
inclined to mutating zeros into ones
than I initially expected
both of these are plausible stories
and so that means in this region we're
only going to be able to learn partially
there's a cap on the amount of learning
that happens there will be some learning
though right because if you get
arbitrarily many signals then you learn
uh you know you have a story for the pie
that would make
um the state of the world equaling one
be true and the pi that would make the
state of the world equaling zero would
be true right and those stories have
different likelihoods so you do glean
something from that but you can't fully
learn the state of the world yeah yeah
I'm missing something here if at any
time T you can learn something
why can't you just by learning this a
gazillion times learn everything and do
it at every time and therefore like
having n of T grow crazy fast
learn everything in the end
so
so let's let's see as nft grows large
yeah
you learn you're basically your your uh
as NFC grows large you get a really
accurate estimate of uh this percentage
of ones that thing that object is going
to converge but if it converges to
somewhere in L of T and M of T you have
equally good stories or sorry not
equally good stories but you have
stories to tell for what pi must have
been
the state of the world to have been one
and you observed so many ones or what pi
must have been for the state of the
world to have been zero and to have
observed so many ones in the case where
the percentage of ones that you see
Falls outside of this interval
then you learn the truth so if I hear
more than M of T signals or uh uh if I
the fraction of ones I hear is larger
than M of T the fraction of ones that I
hear is smaller than
I'm going to be able to learn the truth
right but on this intermediate interval
it's indeterminate there's an
identification problem
can I ask quickly about that
identification problem yeah because you
kind of slipped into it in your language
but I don't know if you meant to
are those stories that I could tell
myself are they equally good they're not
equally good and that's why there's
partial learning okay that's right
they're not equally good and so I say
okay well this pie is more likely than
the pie that would have made it so that
the state of the world is zero and so I
update a little bit towards uh one
rather than zero right that's in the
finite T case
but what happens now as T goes to
Infinity
now it's going to turn out that the
probability that these percentage of
ones that I observe Falls in this
interval L of t m of T is going to go to
one so I'm always going to be in this
indeterminate region moreover the
rationalizing pies are going to converge
to each other
so the pies that would make it so that
the state of the world is one are going
to be very close to the pie that makes
it so the state of the world is zero
right and this is an atomless
distribution
and so the likelihood of both stories is
the same and so we end up not learning
anything in the limit
I'll just ask words this question a
different way it seems like if the tree
is bushy enough then there's enough
information in these genetics papers
there's enough information there's some
race between the growth of the tree and
the corruption rate hence that must be I
think implicit in the question is if n
of T grows fast enough then the number
of copies can overcome the coding areas
so that's when I'm not showing up in the
intuitions you're describing yeah
yeah so maybe uh the so the culprit is
definitely this uncertainty over these
mutation rates because you have this
prior uncertainty over these mutation
rates you're learning not only about the
true state of the world but also about
what the mutation rate must have been
and so you get partial learning about
the state of the world rather than full
learning for a large but fine I.T even
if you increase the number of primary
signals you have access to
you don't fully learn the state
um
so
so my intuition is that you can learn
something from a given tree yeah right
and I can then if I double the tree I
get twice that signal and if I sort of
take a thousand times that tree well
then I learned very well into saying
there's there's a problem there because
there's some correlation between the the
copies of the trees that I'm creating
yeah so so you're not learning if if the
uh percentage of ones that you see Falls
in this interval then you can double or
triple the tree you're not going to be
learning anything more
because you look at this and you say
I have
you essentially you have you have two
stories you have say for a certain value
of pi
you know I can rationalize this guy as
being uh a the state of the world as
being zero and having seen so many ones
and for a different value of pi I can
rationalize the state of the world being
one and having seen so many ones in the
in the case where the the in the case
where the uh the uh network was was not
deep in the case where these guys were
my direct friends
then absolutely everything that you're
saying is going to go through if there's
only small uncertainties then I can
overcome those uncertainties by
listening to sufficiently many signals
but in this case there was no overlap
between uh the region where we determine
the state of the world as being one and
the region would determine the state of
the world as being zero and so here
actually these these parameters the the
state of the world is identified from
the data
in this world the state of the world is
not identified from the data
so maybe Matt you can
as these
chains are getting longer
you're learning about two things right
you're learning about the state and
you're learning about the mutation rate
and the longer the chain becomes the
more you're learning about the mutation
rate and the less you're learning about
the the state itself
and so even if you have an infinite
number of these things you're still
learning a lot more about the mutation
rate than you are about the the actual
State and as this distance goes
higher as as T is growing you're
basically learning almost everything
you're learning is about the mutation
rate and that completely swamps your
ability to learn anything about the
state because if you don't know the
mutation rate you can't really pick up
the state
oh I'm sorry I want to ask for more
um so if you're saying you can't learn
anything in the limit
just say you can't learn anything the
limit as T goes to Infinity it would
seem to me that there would also have to
be in a maximum amount you can learn at
any at any time T so there should be a
function
that the maximum amount you can learn at
any time t for whatever n of T is
and that function goes to zero s t
equals infinity okay perfect so uh so so
maybe maybe maybe this would help
when the dis when the depth is one you
learn the full amount when the depth is
two you might learn the full amount
there's going to be a certain level of
depth at which M of T is going to be
larger than L of t
before that you will learn the full
amount
after that it starts to you have a cap
on the amount that you can learn
right because if you're
once M of T is larger than L of T it's
possible to hear a fraction of one
messages
such that you can't tell apart whether
the state of the world is zero or the
state of the world is one and so that
puts a cap on the amount that you can
learn and as T grows larger this
interval grows and the probability that
you fall inside that interval goes to
one
and you won't be able to learn anything
so the way this looks is you learn you
can learn fully you can learn fully you
can learn fully with arbitrarily many
um primary sources but at some point
there's a cap to how much you can learn
and from then onwards it's going to
decrease the amount that you can learn
and it's going to vanish to zero
of course so
I'm going to
should I move on
so let me just make a
a quick comment about the role of
asymmetries here
before we go on can I ask about the
finite case sure so the the things that
you put up in the very beginning that's
finite right
that's right so can we
so can we learn something I mean now I'm
just trying to do this in my head but
maybe you've already thought about it
can we take what you've done and
interpret what happened in that in those
situations well if these if the net
these chains were sufficiently long then
it would say that in those situations
even with arbitrarily many signals
there's a cap to the amount that we've
learned that would be the nature of the
result rather than saying you can't
learn anything
the limiting result is that you can't
learn anything at all
right so those people
at Circle they learned something
people in Oxford Circle did learn
something
um
so I wanted to give that more as an
example of mutation rates
um but rather than take it super
seriously and say that they're not
learning anything in that context but
maybe they didn't learn as much as they
could because of uh the
maybe they didn't learn as much as they
could because they didn't have
sufficiently many signals right or maybe
even if they had sufficiently many
signals and a lot of communication on
that issue they still wouldn't have
learned
um perfectly what the true state of the
world is because they would said look
all sorts of noises happening right so
you might be in either one of those
worlds this is talking about the world
where you've you've made the number of
chains that you have access to as large
as possible and you still don't learn
and I don't know in that case what's the
limiting factor to learn
so
I just want to make a comment about the
role of asymmetries in this result
um you can you know I don't want you to
look at that result and say Okay small
uncertainties make it impossible to
learn you actually need something else
so if we actually impose that mu 1 0 is
equal to Mu zero one
and the learner doesn't know exactly
what new is then it turns out that if
the prior on mu is bounded away from one
half we can hear from sufficiently many
sources such that we learn the true
state of the world so you actually need
the asymmetry you need uncertainty about
these relative rates of mutation plus
this uncertainty in order to create the
identification problem that arises
okay so what's the upshot of all this
well one way you can interpret this is
saying when primary sources are distant
if people start out with heterogeneous
beliefs even if they're fully evasion
you can see a preponderance of
communication and still have no
consensus
people might be talking about
avocados and cholesterol every day all
day and still might be stuck in their
own dogmatic camps whether or not
they're good
so
um I think I'm seven minutes I'll I'll
talk a little bit about an extension so
so far we consider the case where P1 is
equal to P naught right but in practice
of course
um it gave some examples for why the
survival probabilities of different
types of messages might be different
and in that case you learn not only from
the content of the messages that you see
but you also learn from the frequency
with which uh you hear communication on
an issue so I might not really watch the
news but if I see that the president's
on the news every day then I might start
to wonder like you know what's up with
this guy in my up you know update
favorably or unfavorably on that basis
or alternatively you know there's some
technology that I know a bunch of people
are working on are super excited about
but I still haven't heard any
breakthroughs about it I start to get
suspicious and wonder maybe there really
was nothing there
so some simple intuitions are the the
world where uh the survival probability
of one message is very different uh than
the other
um this is going to favor learning from
survival
okay counting just the frequency of
messages that you see
um the world where uh the uh
probabilities of survival of these
different messages are the same is going
to favor learning from
content and similarly we can uh you know
to the learning from content case we can
Define uh you know posterior beliefs
when agents are learning from survival
this is object BS of t
um this is the posterior belief that the
state of the world is one given that K
of T messages survive to reach you out
of n of teachings okay so this is you're
not actually looking at them uh you're
just counting the number of messages
that you've got
and similarly we can Define a threshold
for survival for an agent who only
counts messages
and the Dilemma says that
uh again in the case where we're
learning from survival we that
thresholds for learning exists and again
it turns out to be some exponential
threshold
it's also going to be the case that in
this world where uh probabilities of
survival are are different
that uh we we get an impossibility
result uh when the relative mutation
rates are unknown
so it doesn't help us on that front
let me take stock of of uh what we
discussed so far
you've said that noisy relay makes
social learning hard and it's possible
to see a lot of communication about some
issue and still not have any consensus
an alternative story for why this might
be is that people aren't fully patient
so you tell them all sorts of things
they just throw that information out
they don't really update
and so a question you might ask is
what's the real bottleneck for learning
is it that we have noisy relay and long
chains and so we rationally don't learn
a lot from the information that we see
because there's not a lot of content
there or is it that there is a lot of
content and you know we see a
preponderance of communication but
people throw out the information that
they hear and that's the reason why we
don't see a lot of learning
well the answer is you know I don't know
um of course if you uh believe that
agents are throwing everything that they
hear out then of course that's going to
be the bottleneck to learning but I'm
going to show you a theoretical point in
favor of the
um the argument that we're making if you
believe agents are throwing out
information but they're not completely
crazy
so let B denote the evasion agent who
learns from both survival of messages
and their content
the survival agent s is someone who pays
attention only to the number of messages
received so they they consider the
frequency with which they're you know
contacted about some issue but they
don't actually pay attention to the
content of those messages and these kind
of Agents would guess one if the number
of messages that survive to reach them
exceeds a certain threshold
that's it
and third there's a Content agency who
pays attention only to the content of
messages received
so these agents would look at the
fraction of ones that they received and
they would only guess that the state of
the world is one if the fraction
exceeded a certain amount threshold
proposition 2 says that for any
probabilities P1 and P naught in zero
one and mu sub zero one and mu sub 1 0
and 0 to one half the threshold for
learning for the Bayesian agent is the
same as the better of the thresholds for
learning for the survival agent and the
content agent
being that it's okay to ignore the less
important dimension of information
you can throw it out and in the limit
you're going to need just as many
signals as a fully Bayesian agent would
and so it's not really that big a deal
that you're ignoring this less important
damage
of course this is in the asymptotic case
we also have some results for the bounds
on uh the value of considering both
dimensions in the case where where T is
fine right and so one way to interpret
this kind of result is that you know if
you have limited Learners and they're
throwing out information but they're
throwing out information in a kind of
reasonable way by maybe ignoring the
less important dimension of information
then that story alone can't explain why
you see a failure to learn in instances
where you see a preponderance of
communication
if that's the way you believe that
Learners are behaving then we would
still maybe at least within the context
of this framework need to rely on these
messages not having a lot of content do
you understand which is the less
important Dimension based on the so
that's going to depend on the uh
parameter values
um it turns out that in asymptotically
if
if the probabilities of survival of both
messages are the same then of course you
would want to learn from content but in
the other cases
it's going to be better to learn from
survival rather than
uh so I'm out of time so let me just
State the main takeaways we have a
simple and reduced form model of noisy
relay of messages and networks
um and we showed that when the distance
to primary sources increases this
increases the information burden on
agents to learn
but really this possibility of learning
result is a knife edge case typically
even slight uncertainties are going to
severely limit the scope for learning
and so denser networks can't really make
up for longer paths and insofar as
things like the internet might have
lengthened the uh the paths of
communication then this says that that
kind of effect might be very damaging
for our ability to learn uh from our
neighbors okay now one thing that we
didn't discuss here is what happens when
sources are both near from you and far
from you in the network
but if you include the possibility of
nearby sources and you know who's nearby
and you know who's far away then you
ignore the far away guys and you listen
to the nearby guys because there's less
of a chance for noise to have built up
but if you don't know if messages don't
come tagged with where they arose in the
network then again the sort of distant
messages are going to wash away the
information uh that you can you can
delete from what you hear but that also
suggests the possibility of you know
trying various policies that would
improve uh the ability of agents to
learn for example by placing things like
forward incomes
which might selectively harm far away
messages more increase the probability
that they get dropped before they reach
you more than they increase the
probability of nearby messages getting
dropped okay and so in a companion paper
we we look at policies of that sort yeah
another question on the last slide it
seems like there's other work that
suggests that a good policy is to
restrict the number of times that a
particular message can be forwarded to
stop uh fake news from spreading really
quickly
um when this like there seems to be a
bit of a tension between this and that
because if if each person can't afford
it that many times you're going to end
up with longer chains it would seems
um yeah so uh in fact that is the kind
of policy that we consider in the paper
where uh there are caps on the number of
times you can forward a given message
um
and if agents have multiple friends
these kind of caps mean that they
randomly select some of their friends to
share these messages with and not others
and so if you have predecessors that
would sort of lead up to uh you know
hearing this information then with some
chance those predecessors don't hear it
so that reduces your chance of of
hearing the same information and that's
what makes it so that selectively
messages that arose far away from you in
the network are less likely to have made
it down to you because at some point
they might have chosen to share that
with someone who wasn't your predecessor
rather than someone who was your
predecessor and so you hear more
information when you impose those caps
uh from people who are close by to you
in the network than people who are far
away and that's the sense in which you
sort of reduce the chance for the reduce
the chance for noise to build up
um along chains
questions
so so it requires that the information
just not spread if it's spreading then
you're going to be better off having it
closer but if it's not spreading that's
right and there's a trade-off right
because you're you're cutting the amount
of communication that happens that's
going to hamper learning if you do too
much of it
um at the same time you're also
shortening the length of chains
and so there's a going to be an interior
Optimum for how much you would want to
do uh this sort of capping policy
third questions
so now let's thank Suraj again
[Applause]